je ne comprends pas comment sans aucune
corde et en penchant autant ces bateaux
ne basculent pas et c'est de faire tenir
un truc en équilibre sur l'eau vous
allez voir ça va être un échec tous les
enfants qui ont mis leurs jouets en
forme de bateau dans une piscine peuvent
en témoigner ça tombe que dire aussi
d'un navire comme les plus gros
porte-conteneur du monde 400 mètres de
long de quoi transporter la Tour Eiffel
et presque 200 25000 tonnes comment un
truc aussi lourd fait pour flotter quand
je jette ne serait-ce qu'un petit
caillou de 1 kg il coulent en réalité
les bâtons dans leur structure de
nombreux secrets qui leur permettent
cette prouesse découvrons-les ensemble
en partenariat avec le jeu World of
warship comment les bateaux font-ils
pour flotter pour le comprendre il faut
remonter en Grèce antique à l'époque
d'Archimède c'est lui qui le premier à
compris la physique derrière ce
phénomène de flottaison et ça commence
avec une histoire toute bête le roi de
Syracuse voulait savoir si sa couronne
était vraiment en or à l'époque aucun
moyen de vérifier à moins de faire
fondre la couronne et de comparer son
poids avec du vrai or mais ça serait du
gâchis Archimède trouve à une solution
en allant au bain public c'est gros là à
chaque fois que je rentre dans le bain
le niveau du bain déborde mon volume
déplace de l'eau là c'est l'illumination
il met la couronne dans un bac remplie
d'eau dans un autre bac il met le même
poids que la couronne en vrai or et là
l'eau n'arrive pas la même hauteur la
Couronne a déplacé plus de volume que le
vrai or c'est donc du toc et c'est
logique une tonne d'or une tonne de fer
et une tonne de plume c'est le même
poids mais pas le même volume et
inversement un volume égal ça n'a pas la
même masse un mètre cube d'or pèse 2,45
fois plus que le fer 1 m³ de fer pèse
790 fois plus que la plume c'est ça la
masse volumique et c'était essentiel
pour comprendre pourquoi les objets
flottent je vous explique l'eau c'est
une tonne par mètre cube or vous avez
remarqué un mètre cube de fer cool parce
que plus lourd alors qu'un mètre cube de
plume flotte car plus léger
l'explication c'est la poussée
d'Archimède le liquide exerce une force
vers le haut mais en même temps la
gravité t'attire vers le bas c'est une
bataille pour savoir laquelle des forces
l'emportera pour les bateaux ça tombe
bien un mètre cube de bois et 2,5 fois
moins lourd que l'eau c'est donc la
force Archimède qui l'emporte c'est sur
son principe car Chimène en personne a
pu aider le roi à construire le navire
de ses rêves le syracusia 120 mètres de
long de son soldats une à ta pulpe des
bains publics un temple et des tonnes de
francs tout ça sur ce qui sera le plus
grand et le plus lourd navire de
l'Antiquité on n'osait pas le construire
avant parce qu'on avait peur que ça soit
trop et que ça coule on avait aucun
calcul jusqu'à ce que Archimède prenne
son bain le problème c'est
qu'aujourd'hui les navires ne sont plus
en bois et là c'est qui constitue les
coques à une masse volumique de 8 tonnes
par mètre cube est-ce que 27 fois plus
que le bois et 8 fois plus que l'eau
comment ça fait pour flotter alors on
dit qu'un bateau est fait de bois ou de
fer mais d'un point de vue physique
c'est surtout fait de vide ou plus
exactement d'air qui remplit la
quasi-totalité du volume or l'air ce
n'est qu'un kilo par mètre cube 1000
fois moins que l'eau c'est donc pour ça
qu'un bateau flotte même en faisant
plusieurs tonnes à volume égal l'eau
juste en dessous de lui et encore plus
lourde si on transformait les beurre Ace
en eau pur il pèserait pas 225000 tonnes
mais plus de 1,5 millions vous voyez la
marge énorme qu'on a avant que ça coule
avec ce principe on peut même faire un
bateau en pierre et ça flottera mais là
je sais que certains s'opposent la
question comment ça se passe au niveau
moléculaire comment l'eau fait pour
avoir l'information de ton volume pour
ça il faut qu'on rentre un peu dans les
calculs parce que si demain vous voulez
construire votre bateau en pierre il ne
suffira pas de creuser un trou partant
d'une expérience prenez un disque de
pierre celui-là a un volume pouvant
contenir un litre d'eau la pierre est en
trois fois plus lourde que l'eau le
disque fait naturellement 3 kg
plongeons-la dans l'eau elle coule et
l'eau du fond est déplacée au-dessus de
la pierre l'équivalent d'un litre si on
met un ballon gonflé par dessus il
flotte sans déplacer d'eau maintenant
revenons au Bocal de départ et posons-y
le ballon et la pierre le disque a beau
faire la même masse le même diamètre il
flotte mais notez de choses le ballon a
coulé et de l'eau à déborder c'est très
important le volume immergé du ballon
est de 3 graduations soit 3 litres
pourquoi parce que la pierre fait 3 kg
il faut donc aussi déplacer l'équivalent
de 3 kg d'eau il se trouve que 1 litre
d'eau égal 1 kg voilà pourquoi 3 litres
ont débordé du bocal si vous comprenez
ça vous pouvez fabriquer un bateau
exemple très simple s'il fait 1000 kg il
déplacera 1000 kg d'eau donc 1000 litres
il y aura donc une partie sous l'eau
équivalente à 1000 litres d'air si vous
faites une coque à moitié trop vous
aurez un bateau à moitié sous l'eau et
si le volume d'air est vraiment vraiment
insuffisante la masse volumique du
bateau sera plus grande que l'eau et
vous connaissez le résultat j'espère que
ces calculs vous ont pas dégoûté de
devenir ingénieur naval parce que ça
peut devenir plus compliqué car tous les
zones n'ont pas la même masse volumique
l'eau salée est un peu plus dense l'eau
chaude est un peu moins du coup ton
bateau peut flotter en mer froides et
couler dans un lac chaud attention aussi
au volcan sous-marin qui peuvent rejeter
des gaz et réduire encore plus la
densité de l'eau c'est là que viendrait
les histoires d'horreur sur les
triangles des Bermudes et les nombreux
bateaux qui ont coulé tu arrives bien
chargé dans l'obés l'eau ne te porte
plus plouf voilà pourquoi les règles
internationales imposent au bateau
d'avoir des marquages sur la coque et ne
surtout pas les dépasser TF pour l'eau
douce S c'est pour le salaire en été W
pour l'hiver c'est très précis c'est
indispensable bon ça a l'air compliqué
de contrôler ça densité avec toutes ces
variables heureusement on a inventé un
truc les ballasts des réservoirs qui
peuvent se remplir soit d'eau soit d'air
comprimés imaginez que votre cargo sort
du port vide il va remplir ses
réservoirs d'eau lorsqu'il récupère sa
marchandise on enlève un petit bouchon
présent sous la coque pour vider de
l'eau et la remplacer par la cargaison
le bateau arrive ainsi à contrôler sa
densité c'est exactement le même
principe qui permet tout sous-marin
d'aller sous l'eau il y a pas un petit
volant pour se diriger plus haut plus
bas il doit simplement l'air de l'eau
dans ses ballasts pour descendre ou
revenir à la surface et justement
puisqu'on est dans les navires de guerre
est-ce que ça serait pas le bon moment
de vous parler de notre partenaire du
jour world of warship un MMO qui vont
replonge dans les grandes batailles
maritimes du début du 20e siècle comme
si vous y étiez un carnet l'URSS le
commonwest les Allemands tout ça avec
une liste démentielle de navires à
personnaliser et même des sous-marins en
tant que fan de notre porte-avion le
Charles de Gaulle je vous laisse deviner
ce que j'aime jouer surtout qu'ils ont
rajouté plein de nouveaux croiseurs
français tout ça avec la mise à jour qui
rend les graphismes encore plus
réalistes j'ai passé des heures dans le
ciel avec mon escadrille d'avion pour
canarder les Allemands pour les plus des
terres le jeu vous propose de former des
clans et de faire des parties classées
afin de gagner plusieurs récompenses et
monter dans le classement mondial le jeu
est disponible sur PC et toutes les
plateformes gratuitement si vous
souhaitez rejoindre le champ de bataille
suivez le lien en description et
profitez d'un énorme pack de démarrage
d'une valeur de 25 euros avec le code
vive la France oui monsieur et c'est
celle du général de comment les bateaux
restent stables enfin vous avez sûrement
galéré à faire flotter vos jouets en
forme de bateau là c'est encore beaucoup
plus gros beaucoup plus fin et pourtant
ça tient enfin ça n'a pas toujours été
le cas Audi XVIIe siècle le roi de Suède
a fait construire le bazar le plus gros
navire de l'époque il a été mis à l'eau
on sentait qu'il manquait de stabilité
bah ça n'a pas manqué 2 km parcourus il
s'est retourné mais qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé un problème tout bête de
construction la largeur de la coque
était trop faible les systèmes
d'armement trop lourds le roi avait mis
la pression au constructeur leur
demandant de doubler le nombre de canons
personne n'a osé lui dire que sa santé
mauvais comme tout objet un bateau à un
centre de gravité ce point de
concentration des forces qui permet à
n'importe quoi de rester en équilibre
même si l'eau sur le bout de vos doigts
ce dernier ne bouge jamais au contraire
d'un autre point le centre de Karen lui
se déplace en fonction de la surface de
la cote immergée regardez l'illustration
dès que les axes du centre de gravité
passent de l'autre côté du suivi du
carène le bateau choisir quand vous
montez sur une barre que vous déplacez
son centre de Karen d'où l'instabilité
heureusement c'est pas pareil sur un
gros navire ou du moins votre influence
et bien plus négligeable ça s'explique
déjà par la coque très large les photos
que vous a montré c'est des illusions
d'optique la Pro est très fine pour
briser les vagues mais le reste du
bateau est bien plus évasé il existe
bien sûr plusieurs types de coques une
coque en découpe l'eau ce qui donne plus
de vitesse au contraire d'une coque
ronde qui ralentit mais donne plus de
stabilité pour ne pas chavirer c'est la
meilleure option ensuite la répartition
du poids même pour les passagers il faut
faire attention au placement des
chambres et des activités que tout le
monde ne se retrouve pas d'un seul côté
du navire on va placer les moteurs et
les grosses machines riz tout en bas au
centre pour créer encore plus de
stabilité dans cette vidéo à l'écran la
cargaison du navire s'est détachée et a
glisser d'un côté créant un gros
déséquilibre notez quand même qu'il ne
choisir pas totalement enfin il existe
une petite astuce en dessous des bateaux
vous avez peut-être déjà vu des courses
de voiliers ils vont super vite le vent
les pousser très fort ils sont à moitié
renversés et pourtant ils tiennent c'est
grâce à un outil la quille une planche
très lourde en dessous de la coque qui
va contrebalancer la force du vent il
n'y en a pas sur les gros bateaux mais
ils ont une autre astuce la bulbe des
travaux une sorte d'excroissance un peu
étrange à l'avant elle permet de créer
une vague à l'avant du navire améliorant
l'hydrodynamisme sans perdre en
stabilité c'est surtout utile pour les
bateaux qui pas aller vite sans elle
lourd ralentit le bateau qui va moins
vite et consomme beaucoup plus comment
éviter les naufrages malgré tout ça les
bateaux qui coulent il y en a eu
beaucoup et il y en aura encore on se
souvient tous du Titanic un grand bateau
solide avec plein de passagers jusqu'à
ce que boum un iceberg le trou à faire
entrer de l'eau qui a pris la place de
l'air la densité a augmenté et ça a
coulée coûtant la vie à 1500 personnes
l'événement a tellement choqué qu'une
grande réunion a eu lieu quelques pays
se sont mis d'accord pour signer un
papier exigeant que la construction des
bateaux et des normes claires et
obligatoires avant ça les cloisons des
navires ne devaient pas forcément être
résistants au feu par exemple du coup
couler et bien plus dur qu'à l'époque
mais pas impossible c'est ce que nous a
rappelé la catastrophe du Costa
Concordia le capitaine a décidé de trop
s'approcher de la côte inévitablement le
bateau à heurter un rocher depuis
heureusement la sécurité a été encore
renforcée par exemple sur la plupart des
bateaux même si la coque était percé
avec un trou énorme le navire ne
sombrerait pas et ce grâce aux cloison
étanche dans la coque ce n'est pas tout
le bateau qui saura rempli mais
seulement un compartiment
malheureusement tout navire finira par
couler un jour on estime que la durée de
vie d'un navire à 30 ans moyenne avant
que la coque ne s'abîme trop avec le
temps et un peu comme le Vogue mérite
dans One Piece il faudra un jour qu'il
rejoigne le fond car les bateaux ne sont
pas éternels
[Musique]